ils en avaient rêvé pendant la plus
grande partie de leur vie voilà que ça
devient réalité dans un trop plein
d'émotions il peine à y croire pouvoir
serrer avant de mourir son enfant contre
soi cette nonagénaire sud coréenne n'a
d'yeux que pour son fils ou nord-coréen
pouvoir l'embrasser aussi un frère une
soeur
je suis reconnaissante que tu aies pu
venir ça n'a pas été facile hein tu es
si belle lance-t-elle des rencontres des
retrouvailles parfois après être resté
sans aucune nouvelle des uns et des
autres pendant des décennies certains
ont eu de la difficulté à reconnaître
leurs proches c'est également l'occasion
de faire la connaissance de petits
enfants ou encore de ne veut ni durant
six longues séparations les séparations
de coréens dispersé massivement pour
diverses raisons durant la guerre des
années 1950 reste l'un des vestiges les
plus douloureux de ce conflit fratricide
les deux corées sont toujours
techniquement en guerre
la reprise des réunions familiales après
trois ans d'interruption est un autre
signe du réchauffement intercoréen
amorcé en début d'année
seoul voudrait qu'elle ait lieu plus
souvent quelques 57000 sud coréens sont
toujours sur les listes d'attentes
la plupart ont plus de 80 ans voire 90
ans le temps presse toutefois pyonyang
is it à régulariser ces rencontres c'est
lui servirait du temps de mener des
changes
les réunions de cette semaine sont très
encadrées par les autorités
nord-coréennes
les familles n'ont pas beaucoup de
moments à elles seules elles se
rencontrent pendant une dizaine d'heures
réparties sur trois jours
mais elle semble en goûter chaque minute
comme le doyen de la réunion un
sud-coréen deux cents un an avant le
jour du départ qui s'annonce comme
chaque fois déchirant avec l'impression
de s'être vu probablement pour la
dernière
ici un libéro pas du canada pékin